[Music]
how's it going everybody it has been an
exciting past few days with Avengers 4
because of all the leaks that have been
coming out and if you don't know what
I'm talking about you can check out the
link above to get caught up but today we
are going to be talking about something
that has not been talked about much
because it is so far away and that is
guardians of the galaxy vol 3
unfortunately guardians of the galaxy 3
is a very long way away not coming out
until 2020 however that does not stop
the theories from pouring in today we'll
be talking about a theory that if it
pans out to be true will be pretty
interesting before we get started be
sure to hit that subscribe button to
stay up to date on guardians of the
galaxy 3 I've been just four and all
things marvel so this theory states that
mantis and star-lord are actually
related or more specifically they're
actually half-brother and half-sister if
you think anything like I do you have
probably already said nope just like I
did but if we break it down it actually
makes a lot of sense let's go back to
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 where ego
talks about his expansion the expansion
is what ego finds to be his purpose and
it is his plan for him to become the
whole entire universe his plan to do
this was to take pieces of him and put
them on thousands and thousands of
different planets these pieces of him
would basically then absorb each planet
until he essentially becomes every
single planet in the universe therefore
becoming the universe his only problem
was that him as a single celestial bean
did not have enough power to do the plan
on his own so what did he do
he went across the universe and he mated
with a bunch of different species in the
hopes that he would have a child that
inherited his celestial gene but we go
on to find out that with each child that
he had up until Peter none of them
inherited the celestial gene and he
killed them all or did he
if you take a look at this photo it
shows a bunch of different species that
ego mated with and had children with if
you look carefully in the upper left
hand corner you can see that ego is with
a species that is just like mantis
could mantas be the child of ego and the
species that we see in this photo she
might not inherit the celestial gene but
she is very powerful
she's an empath and can read people's
emotions and she was strong enough to
keep eagle asleep until she got hit in
the head and got knocked out and she was
even strong enough to subdue Thanos
until star-lord started whaling on him
so if she is the child of ego she may
not have carried enough celestial genes
to be strong enough for the expansion
but she definitely is strong and she
obviously would have gotten that from
ego so she tells Drax that ego found her
in the larva state and then raised her
as his own but what I think is really at
ego actually made it with mantises
mother had mantis as a child and
realized that she had the ability to put
him to sleep
so he decided that even though she
didn't carry the celestial gene or at
least not enough to help him with the
expansion she still served a purpose and
mantis even mentions this when she says
I'm a flea with a purpose
but since mantis doesn't have the
celestial gene it would make sense that
ego as a celestial would not want mantis
to know that he's her father so he made
up some story about finding her so this
is the theory going around that mantis
and star-lord are related and it's worth
noting that James Gunn has not come out
on any type of social media to comment
about this and he usually does he's
pretty great at interacting with fans
and he's sometimes pretty quick to shut
down some fan theories so who knows this
theory could be true or it could be just
completely and totally false and this
could all just be coincidence maybe it's
something that they'll reveal to us in
guardians of the galaxy volume 3 in
forever years from now but until then
let me know what your thoughts are do
you think they're related do you not
think they're related and this is just a
coincidence let me know in the comments
below if you enjoyed this video please
hit that thumbs up button and don't
forget to subscribe to my channel to
join the wolf gang and stay up-to-date
on guardians of the galaxy vol 3
Avengers for all things Marvel DC and
superhero thank you so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]